so 2020 has been quite there instead of
presenting a standard scare of the
bejesus out of you monster
let's give our minds and our adrenaline
a rest because isn't that what we all
need right now if the demonic knuckle of
e
is on the disgusting end of the monster
spectrum the kasaganaga sits on the
adorable
opposite end a sky deity from the
mythology of the toba peoples of south
america
the kasaganaga appears as a small hairy
creature with short legs
who fell out of the clouds and needs a
little human help to return to the sky
it has the ability to bring rain
lightning and thunder
and a history of helping the indigenous
people of south america
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
the kasuganaga hails from the grand
chaco region of south america
which includes modern day argentina
bolivia and paraguay
because it is spread across many
cultures and regions
it goes by a few names this diminutive
creature is genderless
and its physical appearance across
stories varies as widely as its name
but its most common and defining
characteristic is its ability to control
storms the kasaganaga resides in the
clouds and can be called on by a shaman
or pyoxanak for assistance
it can create thunder control the rain
and command lightning at will
sometimes even emitting lightning from
its mouth
this furry helper is described as having
a small head and a body covered with
long hair like an anteater
with four tiny feet and a long snout or
occasionally as a small multicolored
elephant
some modern depictions of the kasaganaga
add rainbow hair
which may just be a conflation between
it and another
non-human being from topo mythology the
komanalo
described as a rainbow snake that also
brings storms
a rainbow-haired anteater storm deity i
love it
as with many creatures whose origins are
in oral traditions
kasoganaga's name appearance and stories
are influenced by the language religion
and community of its various regions
topa spiritual practices integrate
animism
a world view that asserts that humans
non-human animals and non-living
entities
all have spirits or sentience and
influence the lives of people
part of that belief is that most
non-human entities are capable of
changing into whatever corporeal body
they wish
as if changing clothes meaning the
altering physical depictions of the
kasaganaga across
cultures are not seen as unusual but
most beliefs still
center around the same general narrative
it's a deity who fell from the sky and
needs human help to return
the origin story goes a man out hunting
heard a voice in a clearing
and came upon lightning the creature
spoke to the man
telling him it had fallen from the sky
and could not return to the clouds
the being implored the man for help
asking him to build a large fire so it
could use the smoke to rise back to the
heavens
the creature too small to climb onto the
fire itself
told the man to pick it up and place it
upon the fire
and after to run home immediately he
follows these instructions and when
lightning reaches the sky
a violent thunderstorm covers the
drought-stricken land with a heavy rain
a sign of the entity's gratitude
kasaganaga was so thankful it continued
to protect and watch over the man
communicating with him through the air
and giving him the power to heal people
the man became a shaman and the grateful
sky deity promised he could call upon it
at any time
and if anyone bothered him the
kasaganaga would strike his enemy with
lightning
and kill them so this idea that a human
could interact with a non-human deity
isn't an odd concept for the toba people
in animism non-human entities coexist
with humans
and although not all people can see or
interact with them
their general existence is agreed upon
the role of animism in everyday life of
the toba people
is further demonstrated in their
retelling of historical events
which often involves human and non-human
intervention
the indigenous toba people also known as
the guam
found their land infiltrated by jesuit
missionaries in the 17th century
and eventually part of the grand choco
region was declared
national territory of argentina in 1884.
that same year a military campaign
called the conquest of the chaco desert
led to violent conflict with the guam as
the argentine government
built settlements for further conquest
their pursuits were physical
spiritual and cultural many of the
stories of this period of colonization
include the indigenous people escaping
or even defeating the soldiers
because of communication with entities
one story tells of kasoganaga helping a
group of toba women
captured by the argentine military
during the campaign of occupation of
indigenous communities
six women were collecting carob fruit
when the military seized them
tied them up and forced them to walk
towards a prison camp
while the captors rode horses and
donkeys the women were bound and held
captive at the prison camp and through
communication with kasuganaga
who implored the women to escape that
night if they had
any hope of survival which they did
because we know the story today
for the quan people time is fluid and
history is not always recounted exactly
chronologically
and older oral traditions merge with
modern history
in recent years as the guam continue
their fight for rights to ancestral
territory
non-human figures including the
kasaganaga appear in the retelling of
these modern histories
according to one story an electrical
storm allowed the quan people to set up
roadblocks to prevent a hundred police
officers
from evicting a group of indigenous
people from a local school
the quan people say that the unrelenting
rain thunder and lightning
that afforded them protection and
camouflage was sent by kasaganaga
the storm reportedly ceased only when
both roadblocks were complete
as a creature who still has a supportive
role to play in the lives of the qualm
people today
this monster is different from many of
the other ones i've covered in a few
ways
and since i frequently research monsters
who are destructive vindictive and
downright evil
i find the helpful kasaganaga to be a
welcome relief
and a pleasant and important reminder
that even in 2020
not all monsters are bad
i also would like to hug it but i would
definitely ask permission first
if only there was a plush version of it